blam Wow hi hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to marvel strike
force this is a new mobile game that is
for Marvel so as you may know I'm a
sucker for Marvel movies I mean I'm a
big fan in general but also I like going
to the premieres because pictures like
this one where I Mogollon at Benidorm o
come Babu come out and they show how
much of who fit actually in it but that
just maybe been a donk o cumber bomb
palace hey wait this is marvel strike
force this is a new game that came out
on mobile devices which is pretty much
the only place I've played games
casually anymore and it's about Marvel
pretty much all in general they've got a
whole bunch of different stuff and it's
kind of like a new universe instead of
pulling straight from the movies or
straight from the comics a lot of the
the comet's dive into the idea that
there's a multiverse and this is one of
those multiverses where these guys are
now part of your team and you get to
tell them what to do including training
I'm just getting started with the game
though so we're gonna be exploring at
about the same time I mean I know a bit
I'm playing on the real-life servers but
I haven't gotten any benefits I haven't
gotten any extra coins no extra currency
no nothing which is a little unfair but
oh well it's fine I'll do it anyway so
we're just gonna go into heroes Assemble
is mr. Tony Stark and he'll be electric
get past Elektra to stop kingpin from
delivering interdimensional orbs to a
mysterious benefactor oh okay alright
let's do it I guess so why don't we find
out what strikes is gonna do bout and
good going on here that's a need-to-know
basis if there's one thing we know it's
that Tom Holland cannot keep a secret so
maybe that's for the best
even in this universe all you need
currently need to know is that you need
to stop kingpin and recover those balls
okay geez if I didn't need to know I
wouldn't have asked okay sure okay only
villain characters can participate in
this you can be villains ooh
kingpin said you might come looking for
him your search ends here no no no
listen Elektra you're pretty cool and
all but um
well hoobs huh oh it's so sad oh well
you can hand sorceress well I'm a foot
sorceress but the foot to your face
never mind I'm a hand sorcerer I'm gonna
kick you
bibbity Bop oh one for you to kiss
bleeding bleeding from a kick hard was
that kick bibbity pop oh just an epic
dodge the likes of which I've never seen
before
wow she's pretty good oh all right
here's a webby whoo there you go oh I'm
pretty good I'm not gonna lie I wouldn't
lie to you guys I'm pretty good oh there
was a lot of information that I just
flew by and I didn't see it but it's
probably not important and I don't need
to worry about it very much what is
important is that I got gold on oh wait
I'm getting gold do I get a Wolverine
did I did I just
earn myself a Wolverine commander I'm
leaving you in charge of this matter
I'll check in with you later okay
cool thank you continue to here's the
Punisher does he really count as a hero
okay
so there's all Alcala I got orbs oh boy
okay special wow what did i gay Oh are
they part of the Reavers or something
like that oh I got the Winter Soldier
maybe I don't know
get heroes ready what does ready mean or
group ah okay I'm gonna open an orb now
I guess hey I got that guy who's that
guy ravager Bruce oh good old Ravi
bruisy oh I know him
husky oh this guy Ames security Allen
Ignace ma'am Bolden thank you so much
I guess I'm done I don't have any more
orbs where's my orbs you do I got
ravager bruiser nobody war that's a lot
of that's a lot of people
there's a lot of heroes Oh raids oh
there's raids and oh that's right there
are raids in this game like this game is
surprisingly deep like it's not just on
the surface like clone of a different
mobile game it's actually got a lot of
depth to it and they're trying to make
an original story about it which is kind
of nice like it's got arena for PvP it's
got a ladder for competitiveness
it's got campaigns it's got raids which
I'm interested in if if I go anything
back to my World of Warcraft days when I
was addicted to raiding World of
Warcraft that was good anyway I'm gonna
go back into the fighting because I got
nothing else to do so kingpin is
trapping heroes in interventional orbs
for some mysterious alien it seems like
it's good of them as good of a plot as I
need to get into the action hello
everybody how you doing you good how did
Fisk get his hands on alien tech like
this how did he get his big strong beefy
hands on this stuff the only human in
the entire world with Anne's bigger and
stronger and beefier than mine oh maybe
we shouldn't have got in with just our
fists they've got guns uh plunk hey my
energy no I'm so tired now I didn't
bring any coffee
okay okay and he's gone well if you ever
you know you know you get any bigger
loop wow wow I'm so good literate and by
that I mean literally only spider-man is
really good boink he's got a better gun
he's got a bigger better gun MCMAP gone
don't you laugh but not what the heck
who-who did who do what is that
hootie-hoo hootie-hoo and oh nice dock
on that was a good thing that good thing
that Luke Cage docked good jump in thank
you let's put that gear to good use
spider-man could use some new web
shooters I guess II good your gear to
your gear I get it I know how gear works
it kupe oh yeah that's nice geared up
oh okay good that was awesome all right
we traced the truck back to a covert
base in the mountains Hydra the scary
world domination guys whether they got
to do with this why would they have to
do with the world domination kind of
thing that's so weird we all owe nice
duck Luke way to not take one for the
team
oh pretty cool right
oh maybe I shouldn't have taunted all
the guys with the guns that's probably
not my best move now that I'm thinking
about it this not the best not not my
best move okay and he's done he's done
whoops my bad Blanc and also Blanc there
we go that's what I was looking for Wow
Oh guns and bullets that's pretty cool
oh well you know Luke Cage did fall down
he went boom but you know that's okay
they did have guns yeah see this game's
pretty cool it's like a mixture of like
a small puzzle kind of thing because
there's ways that it moves to interact
where it's like it sometimes it's the
guy next to him and I don't know what it
controls that yet but yeah and then you
get rewards based on how well you do and
I'm not gonna get many good rewards
because I suck kingpin and Hydra
abducting heroes and trapping them in
pools what designs are doing with the
balls once they're here I get the
feeling we're about to find ball Oh
clip her got him oh crap laughing Punk
me hugely puss oh I know who you is
didn't even have to go out and abduct
you guys is the guy from what was it
Avengers 2 or I'm a heel real quick
mostly for my benefit not for you guys
Wow see called it called it called that
oh well there's a lot of finesse for not
a lot of result death what did you do
you did expected that would have blown
you up too but okay I guess we're gonna
go that way alright well my characters
down didn't need him anyway
your Julie Yi's portal is you already
active wait you didn't porno
well love that game bit guy yeah just
keep peppering the old Winter Soldier
over there Luke stop dunking take one
for the team just one Oh
okay goodbye Wow
look if only you knew huh huh please
little please okay goodbye
alright let's hope this finishes you off
uh-oh
welp I can dodge I've got crazy reflexes
never mind
you can't win every Oh train oh oh I got
a oh oh oh I didn't have my back didn't
have my badge that told the enemies how
much more damage I did some dumb oh yeah
comlinks oh there were more my punches
are more hard there you go oh yeah oh
that's good oh that's good oh yeah oh
yeah you see leads portal do you hear do
you remember when there was a portal
okay anyway you got a kick oh this is
gone he's gone why was it gone
alright well you got a vein good and
he's down hmm
there we go interdimensional orbs
genetically-engineered soldiers I picked
a bad day to do school and join streak
yeah you did they did they did let's go
unlock the Punisher I'm a recruit I'm
paying money cuz you know that's how the
Punisher what is with that face that is
what he's like so angry but also curious
what is what expression is that he's
like is the rest of his face is
completely neutral his mouth is just a
little sad remembering his family and
then his eyebrow is this is calling you
from across the room it's so enticing
alright ok Punisher yeah badou here we
go let's train the Punisher yeah you I
was gonna go though I feel stronger
Oh God
i leveled yes yes Colonel fury says he
needs some Viper and some oddly
seductive eyes so he called you think
your worst in Italy
I'm here to do whatever it takes to
complete the mission and get that lady
across the room to me that's me yeah I
can have all of you Oh what that's nice
that's real nice I like that oh I got a
bus now my German accent for this one
you will not stop Hydra and its new
allies from converting this world our
world oh boy this is I bad this is a bad
idea
probably overkill oh it was it was way
overkill
oh no need to do that all right hi
screaming look out oh it's just another
dude okay whatever wait a minute you oh
my Holden Oh what guns are supposed to
be used at a distance oh just so you
know that guns in long range
punch him by Oh missed me oh hi you okay
he's didn't we need to like interrogate
him maybe throwing him off a building
wasn't there like the smartest idea yeah
whatever no one said that we were a
smart team here yeah I'm just sending
orbs through an interdimensional portal
we need to shut it down I guess we do I
guess we do I guess we do need to do
that alright so that is marvel strike
force the good thing about this one
versus a lot of mobile games that I play
is that it's actually a full-fledged
game it's not it's not mechanics to try
to get you to play like it's not trying
to trick you to play it's an actual game
and I like that it's got a lot of depth
to it I didn't get to the raids
obviously because you need to level up a
lot more but I could definitely see me
playing this on a day-to-day basis just
for fun whenever I had some time so
check it out if you want to play the
game for yourself I'll put a link in the
description below where you can download
it for free then you can play it for
yourself thank you everybody so much for
watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye